okay there's continued interest in
speaking with me via discord you can
join the discord i think we've got what
eleven
twelve thousand of our viewers on our
discord server davidpakman.com
discord the waiting lobby is the place
to go
if you would like to talk to me let's go
next to
magnus from scotland magnus you are on
the air
magnus if you unmute yourself we will
all be able to hear you can you hear me
yes i can um
i don't really have a question about the
us
at the moment um but scotland has
our um national elections coming up in a
couple of months
right and i wondered if you had any
thoughts on that i'm not expecting you
to
but just in case you did you know i i'm
not informed enough to be able to
comment
unfortunately okay well
that's all i've got thanks well what's
going on vaccination wise in scotland
uh we we're doing it differently to
england and i think we got our care home
and
that lot of people done earlier than
england i think we're about level
at the moment uh
i think 60 year olds are being done at
the moment
when are you expecting to be able to get
vaccinated
two three months i'm in the last group
to be done so
i've not looked into it and then how
about as far as like
uh you know in the u.s a big thing has
been for example
to support the restaurant industry by
getting takeout or maybe you
you call it takeaway in scotland is this
something that people are doing to rally
behind restaurants in edinburgh
and i i've not been doing it i've been
cooking my own stuff fair just because i
like cooking
that's fair all right very good okay uh
magnus thank you so much for the call i
appreciate it
thanks all right magnus checking in from
scotland very important
let's go next to varun from new delhi
varun you were on the air oh hey david
how are you um well how are you
i'm doing well okay uh i just had a
simple question
you know um barring for the moment that
the uh minimum wage increase isn't going
to be passed that you know it's been
removed from the relief bill
i mean it was removed from the relief
bill
if it had been passed and um
you eventually got to a 15 minimum wage
how would that
affect uh you know the minimum wage
recipients
functional liquidity because if that
elevates them beyond the
uh qualification threshold like the
minimum for um
you know i guess broadly welfare
benefits so you know snap benefits
and uh you know low-income housing that
sort of thing
i mean basically all their money is just
going to go back into that stuff so you
argue in favor of
uh demand side stimulus but you know how
does that work out does it have to be
accompanied with other
you know sort of policies that you know
raise the uh you know the income
threshold to qualify for these things
so this is a great question and the crux
of the question is
if you make nine bucks an hour but in
addition you qualify for certain welfare
benefits and then you have some
total income for the year which is your
nine dollar an hour job
plus maybe you know 180 bucks a month in
food stamps you add it all together and
then you say okay
we're going to give you 15 an hour but
as a result of that you will exceed the
income threshold
for some of these benefits do you really
come out ahead that's the crux of your
question right
yeah basically yeah it's a it's a very
fair question
the answer is it depends
significantly on what's going on at the
state
level in many uh which is which is
different from for many people
but you have to account for a couple of
different things
one is is a 15 minimum wage
for example like alabama has no state
minimum wage so in alabama the minute or
maybe it's mississippi maybe it's both
the minimum wage in some of these states
is the federal which is 7.25 so 15 is
more than doubling
the impact there on eligibility for
programs
is going to be very different than in a
state that already has an 11
minimum wage and it goes to 15. and
that's going to vary
uh state by state you also have to
remember that a lot of people who
qualify for benefits don't actually
go through the process of getting them
because the they either don't know that
the benefits are available
or the system is cumbersome or
complicated or whatever the case may be
so while there's no question that there
are some people who will get a raise
from a minimum wage increase
and they'll lose something on the
welfare side
when you account for the difference in
money in the pocket versus a housing
subsidy
money in the pocket versus food stamps
people who don't understand
or avail themselves of these systems the
the net benefit is still
significant but that doesn't mean what
you're saying doesn't exist and i think
it's important to consider it
oh okay thanks all right no problem
um yeah these are like problems to solve
rather than reasons not to increase the
minimum wage you know if the minimum
wage should be higher on an inflation
adjusted productivity adjusted whatever
basis
you do it and then you figure out how to
solve that that problem
as an example that varun uh brought up
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com pacman